Welcome to "Ear Biscuits", the podcast,
where two lifelong friends,
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
What just happened?
Something in your throat?
I'm battling, I'm fighting off,
it's not "COVID", just so, you know,
there's a very mild cold that's
going through my household
and I'm, like, in day
three of fighting it.
And this is as bad as it's got.
And it's like, every once in a while,
just a slight scratch in my throat.
Well, I don't want to
get it, dude, because-
It already happened in your family,
is what Christy told me.
'Cause Christy and I have a
romantic getaway this weekend
and I don't want be hacking
and thinking about the fact
that you gave me something.
So, don't do this.
Even if, in its worst,
all it got to for Shepherd, was
like a sore throat for a day
and then, it went away.
And I'm tougher than he is.
And so, the worse that it's gotten for me,
is this slight impact in my speech.
So, as long as you can still,
if your voice cracks a little bit
when you're making love to your wife,
I think, that's totally acceptable.
It kicked .
Yeah, it's just, kind of,
part of the reckless abandon
of the weekend.
One day, Shepherd's gonna
be stronger than you
and it's gonna happen a
lot quicker than you think.
And I'm Link.
This week at "The Round
Table of Dim Lighting",
we're talking
about your most disturbing
slash spooky experiences,
because that's the prompt that we put out
when we tweeted,
"We want to hear
about your most disturbing
slash spooky experiences.
Give us a call and share
your story at 1-888-EARPOD1."
And here, we are read-
not reading, we're listening to these.
And you can, also, use "#EarBiscuits"
and we will read the stuff that you send.
So-
One of the more disturbing things
that has happened to me
in the past five minutes,
is seeing you sit down with a "Starbuck",
just so you know, when
you have one serving
of a "Starbucks" thing is a "Starbuck".
Okay.
Okay?
All right.
So, you have a "Starbuck"
and the name on it is Blake,
which is just, so-
Matt's my name.
I mean, it's just amazing.
What, now, what, did you say "Link"?
I said, "Link".
I mean, this is such a trope.
But it's amazing to me.
Link, Blake.
Blake.
Blink.
I mean, it doesn't really matter.
I was in the drive-through.
Oh!
It wasn't like they-
Oh, yeah, yeah, drive-through,
they don't care.
But they're gonna call out Blake,
you would never go to that.
I would never go to that,
Yes, I would.
I'm going to, right now-
Well, if they said Blake,
you'd go up and you'd be like,
"Link?
Oh, I guess, Blake, is
there a Blake here?"
Because Lilly works at a "Starbucks", now,
I'm totally on the
employees' side of this,
like, I'm not gonna-
You can't help it.
I'm not gonna criticize it
and my feelings aren't hurt.
I think, the thing that's more disturbing
than you being called Blake,
is the fact that you have a "Starbuck",
like, you're so routine-oriented
that anytime anybody around here is like,
"Hey, we're getting 'Starbucks',
you're like, "No, thanks."
Like-
Yeah.
So, what series of events,
led you to going to "Starbucks"
and going through the drive-through
and getting a coffee for Blake?
You know what, Rhett?
How did this happen?
I feel very seen right now, thank you.
I've never seen you with one of these,
except for like, a set on
something we're working on.
I passed by the "Starbucks"
and there's just line
going to that drive-through
and I just always look at it with disdain,
'cause it's clogging up my
exit artery to get to work.
And I'm never getting in that line.
So, for the first time ever,
today, I got in that line.
I hit snooze.
You know, we had a dinner last night?
I was there.
Gosh! I was telling you, I ate too much.
Talk about a horror story,
disturbing and spooky experience,
just too much decadent sauciness.
You're the only one, who
took home a doggy bag.
Did you see?
First of all-
That's true.
This place served food,
at least, your food and my
food were served in a dog bowl.
Yeah, it was like-
Like, if you are gonna get a bowl,
for, like, a large dog,
like, we're talking
German Shepherd and up,
that was what we were served in.
Yeah.
And mine, I mean, you know who I am,
I saw "Lobster Risotto" on
the menu and I was like,
"Check please," or
whatever, "Yes, please."
And I love the fact that you
and Christy play this game
where it's like, you
know what, like, what-
She knew what I was gonna do.
She always knows what
you're gonna order, because-
And she did, she almost got it.
And it had one pound of lobster in it.
I ate every damn bit of it.
I got this shrimp-
Just like a dog.
"Shrimp Alfredo Penne Pasta",
it was amazing.
But yeah, I got to a point
where I was just eating the shrimps.
Yeah, so much pasta left-
But we had so many appetizers.
What I'm saying, was I felt,
kind of, bad going to sleep
and then, I, like, felt
bad when I woke up.
It was a gut hangover.
Yeah.
And so, I just kept hitting snooze.
I did not want to try
to like, I didn't want
my body to go upright.
And so, that set me on a path
of like, being, kind of, in a tizzy.
' Cause I'm up against dropping Lando off
at a specific time.
I can't, actually, be late for that,
'cause he can't stand it
if I drop him off late.
Cool.
So, then, I had made my
smoothie at the last second
and I did decide to eat my smoothie,
even though, no part of me wanted to.
Was it a rush smoothie?
It was a rush and I-
So, you didn't eat it with a spoon?
I made a coffee at the same time.
I still ate it with a spoon.
So, you ate a smoothie-
I was in a real hurry.
In a rush with a spoon.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm really glad, I wasn't there for that.
It just makes me feel,
like, there's still
some sanity in my life.
You know, how gra-
That I eat that smoothie-
You do know how gravity
and throats work, right?
It's like liquids, throats and gravity,
a nice project by Rhett McLaughlin.
So, Link will know how
to drink a smoothie.
Yeah, it does say a lot,
like, as in a hurry as I was,
I was still gonna do that.
But I'd made my coffee in parallel
as opposed to what I normally do,
which is eat my smoothie
out of my coffee mug
after I've finished my
coffee an hour earlier.
Really?
Yeah, I drink my coffee,
right when I get up
and then, I go get ready
and then, I come back down
and I make my smoothie
and I pour it in my coffee cup.
Your whole smoothie
fits in your coffee cup?
No, I have to pour it twice.
Hmm.
So, there's less-
Is that so, you have less to clean up?
Yes.
You want your smoothie to
taste a little coffee-esque?
No, there's less to clean up.
I had to make my coffee
in parallel this morning
with my smoothie that went into a cup
and then, I just ran out of the
door and I forgot my coffee.
Because I, usually, have
drunk my coffee earlier.
I never take a coffee in the car.
Okay, what's the over-under
on you having your wallet, right now?
I'm gonna say, that there is a 75% chance,
you do not have your-
I have my wallet.
You do have your wallet?
How did that happen?
Because when we drove home last night,
I took it out of my pocket and I put it
in the console of my car.
Oh, so, it was in your car!
I keep my wallet in my car, yes.
That's where I keep it.
So, whenever we go somewhere in your car,
that's why I never have my wallet.
So, if somebody steals your car,
they can, also, steal your identity.
Just good thing to note.
Yep and I-
They get a little two-for-one.
And I, usually, leave
my keys in my car, too.
Right.
So, it's like, I just make it easy.
They can, also, get in your house.
It's just like, , yeah.
They can just assume your life.
And there's a mask of me in the glove box.
There's like, a very
realistic mask of my face.
But you're gonna have
to drink that smoothie,
every morning with a spoon.
With a spoon.
Eat it with a spoon, sorry.
Right, like that.
As long as you do that,
my family will not notice the difference.
Like, kill me, put on my mask,
just don't ever think
about drinking a smoothie
without a spoon.
And you know what?
You'll be living the life, man.
'Cause I have quite a life.
I haven't been able to calibrate my life,
since, I'm trying, once again,
with the thing I tried last year,
where I'm eating in a restricted window
from, like, noon to 8:00 PM, right?
And so, not eating in the morning,
means I'm not getting my
smoothie in the morning.
And I believe, that the smoothie
had a bunch of nutrients
that, now, I'm, probably,
not getting from other meals.
Yeah, that's gotta become
your launch, or your dinner.
And so, I'm a little bit torn.
I'm trying-
That's why I forced myself
to eat the smoothie this morning.
Plus, there's, like, I put so
much flaxseed in that thing.
It's the the only thing
that, like, I count on
that to keep me regular.
I don't want to go there, but.
Yeah, I don't know, I haven't
straightened it out yet.
You're missing out, dude.
Well, I need to get some of that.
I had some of that green stuff.
We don't have a sponsor,
like, everyone is sponsored
by "Athletic Greens",
maybe, we should be.
But I use something else,
other than "Athletic Greens",
that is, also, not a sponsor.
But I ran out of it.
But it's, essentially, like powder
that I think, just makes you
feel like a super person.
But I ran out of that,
so, maybe, that's why I got
a little scratchy throat.
You talking about "Ka'Chava"?
No, I'm talking about-
That's what I use.
Green-
Not a sponsor.
Similar stuff.
They should be a sponsor.
Yeah, we need to get
one of these sponsors,
one of these green sponsors.
And I'll start doing it, again.
I want to get into a voicemail.
Do you?
Yeah.
All right.
Before you play it,
I think, we need to take the
coast-to-coast approach, here.
Okay.
Which is, you don't-
like the "Reddit" approach,
which I'm not a huge fan of "Reddit",
but the thing I do like about "Reddit",
is when people tell a story,
you're not, really, supposed to question
whether or not they're lying.
Yeah, yeah.
So, we're-
What's the point of that?
We're choosing to believe
that all these things happened to you
and we're not gonna try to poke hose into-
hose, we're not gonna poke
hose or holes into your story.
Yeah.
What's a hole in hose called?
A ho-hole.
A ho-hole?
It's for the dirt to go through.
You know, like, I don't
know, I'll play it.
You know, like, a rip in .
That's all I'm talking about, here.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
So, the creepiest thing
that ever happened to me,
I lived in a haunted house
when I was in high school
and I would see this little girl,
pretty much, all the time.
And a bunch of my family members saw her,
my friends saw her.
But the creepiest thing that happened,
is we were outside, watching a tornado,
and I came back inside,
I looked down the hall
and this girl is walking down the hall
and she's, probably, three foot,
three-and-a-half-foot tall.
And as she gets closer,
I realize that she doesn't have a face
and she floats up to me
and floats right through me
and disappeared.
And that's, probably, the creepiest thing
that I've ever experienced.
Man, I got a little bit,
my cackles stood up.
What is that when it happens?
Your cockles.
Cockles?
No, my cockle's fine.
I think, it's cockles.
My cockle did not respond to that story,
my cackles.
Well, I mean, the fact that
halfway through this story,
there's a tornado in it
and the story's not
even about the tornado.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like, watching the tornado-
"Yeah, we got this haunted house
with a little woman in it,
turns out be faceless,
we were outside watching a tornado once,"
like, "Hey, I feel you."
I feel that, like, if a
tornado was coming up,
I think, I would really wanna watch it.
But, ah!
And then, just as long as
I know where I'm gonna run-
If you've got a basement of sorts.
But then you come back inside,
this is what we talked
about last week, man.
Man.
You got the little woman,
or the girl, because-
This is a common story,
a faceless little girl.
This is a common thing
where people see a person
of a certain type, right?
Even down there at the
hotel in Chester, Arkansas
that our good friends,
Lance and Lacey run,
there's a story of a guy, who died there
and there's like, I don't
know, all the details,
but multiple people will
see that guy, right?
And so, of course, there's the-
Multiple people thing that's-
Well, there's a power of suggestibility,
a power of suggestion.
It's like, "Okay, if I'm gonna see some,"
but, again, this happens so often,
I choose to believe
that people are seeing,
they are seeing something
that is coming across to them,
like, they're seeing a
little girl without a face
in this sense.
Floating through him?
What would you do?
I mean, I don't think, I could stand there
and let a ghost fly through me.
Because right before
she floats through me,
she's floating right up to me!
That's a flee situation.
I mean, or play dead or something.
I've never had any experience like this.
But-
Do you want to?
I don't know,
what I would do.
Do you want to have one?
No, no.
Well, to me, I'm of two minds.
One is, of course, I
don't want to be scared.
I, kind of, do, actually.
But it's more, seeing that
would be a super cool thing.
And it would change my worldview,
'cause my worldview, right now,
is that like, "Something must be going on,
but I just really doubt that
it is ghosts or whatever."
I heard somebody talking
about that these paranormal
things are related
to echoes and time.
We don't understand everything,
there is about the nature
of time and space, right?
Okay.
And we've got like every-
I know, I don't.
And I mean, I've read some
popular science books,
where they try to explain
it to people like me,
who are not studied.
But the idea of, essentially, everything
that's ever happened, is always happening.
So, you're, basically,
like, at times, you're
running into other things
that have happened in that space.
So, it isn't, necessarily,
like this little girl died,
her soul remained around and
she's haunting the house.
I mean, maybe.
Again, I don't know,
But what would you do in that scenario?
Now, I think, it is important to know
that, like, they felt like she was there.
This wasn't the first experience.
A tornado is coming, by the way.
Well, I just can't,
at a certain point you're like,
"Yeah, there's a girl here,
we live with her,
she just floated through me,
doesn't have a face."
At a certain point,
you just, kind of, like, have
to live with it, I guess.
But I just don't think-
Well, has anybody ever
been beat up by a ghost?
I would run.
But why?
Has anybody ever been killed by a ghost?
I don't know.
Okay, okay.
Brian said, we've got a story, okay.
Oh gosh! We got someone who died?
Which number?
Number 20.
Oh, number 20?
All right.
Well, not died, but I mean, this-
Well, all right, let's
listen to number 20, then.
Hi, my name is Vivie and I'm a big fan.
So, this, actually, happened to my mom,
but me and my dad were
there to witness it.
We were moving out of
this totally creepy house.
We didn't even last there six months,
it was so creepy.
One of these creepy things we would hear,
were these footsteps
that would just run across
the hallway upstairs.
It was just like these noises.
And at the time, we
just convinced ourselves
that it was our cat,
I think, we were in denial.
We, really, wanted to
believe it was just a cat.
Anyway, we were moving out.
Me and my dad left, we came back,
my mom was still at the old house
and when we came back,
we hear this loud, toe-curling
scream come from upstairs.
Me and my dad freak out,
we run upstairs where we find my mom,
lying on the ground, crying and praying.
We ask her what the heck happened?
She tells us that she
walked into my bedroom,
where she just instantly felt
this, like, negative energy.
She felt like, she was just
frozen, she couldn't move.
She, suddenly, felt like this
heavy feeling in her chest,
she couldn't breathe.
She tried to pray and
when she tried to pray,
she felt something, like,
grab her and pull her down
and just scratch her whole body.
She looked up and she saw these cracks,
starting to form in the ceiling.
And that really freaked me out,
'cause I told my mom,
like, "I used to see these
cracks form in the ceiling."
I didn't mention it before,
because I was a teenager,
so, I assumed that they
would assume the worst
if I just, "Oh, there's
cracks forming in my ceiling."
Whatever.
So, anyway, we were like,
"We need to get out of here,"
like, we're just done,
like, "Let's just go."
I'm pretty sure, we forgot some stuff.
As we were leaving and
walking out the door,
we hear these footsteps upstairs, go .
So, yeah, totally, wasn't the cat.
As we were in the car,
my mom pulled up her pants
and she had these
unexplained scratch marks,
going down her legs.
So, yeah, that's our scary story.
Hmm.
Good gracious.
They do attack and they,
really, mess up your drywall.
Yeah, man.
That's why you gotta have
them, popcorn ceilings
in your haunted house to
cover up for the cracks.
Okay, I have a physical reaction
when I hear these stories.
I get, like, my, look.
I go into complete denial.
I don't even wanna-
The hair stands up on my, like-
I'm not engaging.
The hair stands up on my arms.
It's so freaky, man.
Your cockles.
You know what?
I believe them.
They don't seem,
just, she seems so level-headed, you know?
Yeah, man, I mean-
If she was my doctor,
I would take the prescriptions, you know?
I would trust this voice.
Too many people, who I trust,
have had experiences
that they can't explain
that I'm sure, somebody smarter than me,
could explain
why it was just their mind
playing tricks on them.
But I just-
Well, you know what?
I can't, Rhett.
But I just don't think, that's
an adequate explanation.
I think, there's something
that we don't understand
that's happening.
I mean-
Yeah.
So, but what would you do?
Because I've never lived
in a haunted house,
I've never had an experience like this,
but there's been a few times,
when I've been alone in my own home
and I think, maybe, a couple of times,
when I've been in, like, a house alone
that wasn't my own home
and that same feeling that I just got
when she was telling that story,
it'll happen to me and I'll
start freaking myself out.
But it comes from within.
It's all from anticipation
and me, imagining what might happen.
But I've never experienced anything.
I don't know, what I would do.
Some people, just, are are like,
"Yeah, we have this particular
presence in our house
and it's weird and it's
something, we talk about,
but we don't feel like we should leave."
I'd leave this situation.
This is a little bit different.
When the family's united and
the mama's been scratched-
When mama gets scratched,
you don't look back.
Don't look back.
Talk about horror scenarios,
I can't think of few that are
worse than if you don't vote.
And then, things that
you wish didn't happen,
start happening-
That's a good segue.
To your local, state
and national government.
Right.
I just wanna remind you,
these midterm elections are important.
Sometimes, the things that you care about,
that affect you on a local level,
it just comes down to thousands,
if not hundreds of votes.
So, we want to, just, clarify
that you have power as an American,
I'm assuming, you're an-
I'm speaking to the Americans, right now,
'cause we have midterm elections.
And we want you to go to the
website that we have created,
"votelikeabeast.com",
so, that you can get in
touch with the issues
and where you stand on 'em.
Get in touch with yourself and the issues
and then, vote and the people.
And we've made it very easy for you
to check your voting status.
And for some states,
I think, you can register
right up until election day.
Some states, there's a deadline,
depends on where you're at.
But you can check that,
based on where you're-
We got your back,
"votelikeabeast.com".
Don't vote how we want you to vote,
but vote how you wanna vote and vote.
Let's go to this one.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
So, I had a spooky encounter
when I was in college.
There was the music and
arts building in my college,
had a small reputation of being haunted
and I was a bit of an insomniac.
So, I did all my practicing
in the middle of the night.
So, one, like, random,
like, Thursday night,
I went to practice at around 2:00 AM
and when I went up to the top floor
where all those practice rooms are
for everyone to practice,
expecting it to be empty,
I heard someone practicing piano
and I thought,
"Okay, I've got a fellow
friend insomniac, here."
But I got a little curious
after I practiced for a bit
and they were still going.
So, I went over to see who it was
and there was nobody in the room.
And I sprinted out of the building
and then, got over it and
practiced there every night
for the rest of my college career.
But it was still very terrifying.
So, did not love that.
Sprinted out of the building.
Yes, right answer.
Coming back every other
time you wanted to practice,
strange-
But why-
Application.
Why does that have to be the answer?
The only thing this ghost
did, was play piano.
That's an olive branch.
Okay.
That's the ghost saying,
"I love music, too-"
What was that?
Did you hear that?
What was that noise?
I think-
farty?
Think, that's my cat.
What?
I don't believe,
you talking about my stomach
growing really loudly,
right now?
Yeah.
I don't think, this mic picked up on it.
Maybe, it did, I don't know.
It's pretty loud.
Is that meal, we ate last night,
is that "Risotto", trying to find his way?
Riso-go.
I don't know.
Because, first of all,
totally get being scared.
I would be scared.
I'm not saying, that I would do this.
But if there were a ghost
that was playing the piano in a room
and you knew, that this
piano was being played,
it would be like-
What about your phone?
Yeah.
That's what you would want.
I think, they know that.
I think, they know,
I think, the ghost protocol is to not-
isn't that like a "Mission:
Impossible - Ghost Protocol"?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think, the ghost protocol,
is to not let iPhones catch you.
They know that.
Android?
That's like the orientation,
like, the one, ghost orientation,
is like, "People bring out the phones,
you stop playing the piano."
Oh.
Okay.
But I don't know, like,
what were they trying to do?
What were they trying to
prove, or trying to say?
Again, I'm trying not to pick it apart,
like, it makes me feel
better to pick it apart.
But we've said, we're not gonna do that.
So, now, I don't have anything to say.
I'm just gonna play another one.
Hi, I'm here to tell you my spooky story.
This is also a completely true story.
Basically, the summer
before seventh grade,
my friends and I,
there were four of us,
we decided to do a "Ouija" board
at her grandmother's house.
Oh!
So, there were four of us in the room,
but, only, three of us
went to the "Ouija" board.
The fourth girl decided
to just text her mom
and she was like, "Oh, they're
gonna do 'Ouija' board."
And she goes, "Oh, don't do it.
When I did it with my friends,
we were about your age and
it was a horrible idea,
like, we had to get a
priest to help us out."
And we're like, "Okay, that's terrifying,
but whatever, we still gonna do it."
So, we put our hands on it
and it all starts moving
and we're like, "What the heck?
What's going on?"
And it gives us these random numbers
and maybe, a few letters.
So, we ask her to look it up,
'cause she was on her phone, anyways
and we get a highway code in Portland
and we're like, "Okay,
that is just random,
whatever, it doesn't matter."
But then, she tells her mom that
and her mom goes, "My friend,
who we were trying to contact,
died in a car crash on
a highway in Portland,
or it died on a car crash in Portland."
And we're like, "Okay,
that's freaky, like, what?"
So, later, we get 9, 2, 3, the numbers
and we're like, "Okay,
what does that mean?"
Like, we're thinking, 9, 2, 3,
maybe, that was the license plate,
you know, blah blah, blah.
She goes, "My friend
died on September 23rd."
And now, we're, like, freaking out.
We're like, "This is crazy."
But we don't get anything after that.
So, this is August, right now,
we're like, "We need a
lookout for September 23rd,
see if anything happens,
something is going on."
And the friend, who hosted it,
on that day, September 23rd,
finds four dead birds in her backyard.
And there were four people in the room.
It's crazy.
So, that's it.
That's my spooky story.
Hope, you enjoy.
If this were a movie, I
wouldn't have ended there.
They would've figured out a way
to, like, write the rest of the movie.
Four dead birds does not make an ending?
An ending does not make, is
what you're trying to say.
Yes.
But see, how do I not just say things
like, "Well, 'Ouija'
board's just like psychics."
It's like, first of all
it's cooperation of people
and then, it's just numbers,
which, like, just
finding some random stuff
and then,
making meaning out of it.
Making connections.
But I'm not gonna go there.
It's impossible not to.
Again, I want to go there, as well.
I think, one of the ironic things-
I didn't go there.
Is that, we did not,
I just think, it's an interesting tidbit.
When we were Christians
and believed vehemently
in the supernatural
and believed that there was a war going.
No, we weren't charismatic.
You were very reformed,
I was pretty reformed.
And in that tradition,
there's not a lot of talk of
demons and angels and stuff.
There's this belief that they exist,
but they're not very active.
So, we tend to have an
almost naturalistic view
of the supernatural world,
even within the Christian tradition.
It's, kind of, fascinating.
And so, any of this "Ouija" board ,
I, just, was like, "This is
just people making connections.
I don't think, that the
devil is wasting his time
with 'Ouija' boards.
It just feels like a dumb distraction,"
is what I thought as a Christian.
It's, actually, post-faith,
when I'm in this place
where I'm like, "Listen, I
realize, now, how little-
I just had this very narrow slice
of my interpretation of reality."
And, now, I'm just like,
"There's so many things
that I don't understand."
And so, I, actually,
have more of an openness
to there being some legitimacy
to these people's experiences.
But still, the skeptic in me,
goes to this place of what you're saying,
which is you're gonna get some numbers,
everybody's moving it.
It's not like, a "Ouija"
board doesn't work
by you placing the little glass on it
and then, everybody stands
back and it moves on its own.
Like, can a ghost do that, too,
or can a demon do that?
Mm-hm .
So, there's always these little things
that, like, "Oh, well,
people are moving it around."
I think, it would've,
like, if I found out that my
kids were at a slumber party
and they were, like, doing
this, a "Ouija" board,
I mean, I think, my first
thing would be like,
"Oh, was it scary, was it fun?"
I would interact with it like a game,
like, the board game that
it sold as, you know?
Yeah, it's in "Walmart", right?
Yeah, probably, in "Walmart".
But going back to, like, our worldview
and how it impacted things
and it just, kind of,
like, we, just, weren't interested in it.
I think, it's because
we, actually, did believe
that we had, I'm gonna say, experiences,
maybe, interactions with
Satan or his minions,
his demons-
Temptations or whatever.
Just talking about, like, temptation,
like, believing lies.
There was a lot of language and teaching
around associating things like that
with an interaction with the dark side,
with, like, with Satan, right?
So, it's, "Okay, I'm not gonna give in
to the power of Satan,
but he's around."
So, it's, kind of, like, I live in a-
yes, Satan can be here,
but I have this belief
that through Jesus,
I have power over Satan
and not in like, a exorcist,
or a vampire with a cross, kind of, way.
That's not how we thought about it.
We didn't think about it that way,
but we thought about it
in a very cerebral, logical, kind of, way
that's like, I didn't spend too much time,
thinking about Satan,
but if you press me, I would say,
"Yeah, like, I'm supposed
to not listen to Satan,
not give in to temptation
and I can be delivered from evil by God."
Right?
So, I think, this level of
proximity that we believed in,
it's like, "Okay, this
experience makes sense,
but it's also, kind of, safe
and it doesn't have this,
like, Satan's never gonna,
or his demons aren't gonna scratch me,
or send some ghost after me or something.
Well, and I was told many times
that "Hey, you don't need
to worry about demons,
like, you don't need to
worry about being possessed,
because a demon can't come into you,
because of the holy spirits
inside of you, already."
So, that was comforting.
But-
Because I'd think, because
of that it was like,
"Okay, I'm not really
interested in 'Ouija' boards,
because I know, how Satan,
or whoever his minions are,
interact with me in my everyday life.
And it's just something
that I've been able to come to grips with
and not be afraid of and not dwell on,
but, also, not seek out,"
like, that's the thing,
is that you don't wanna
start seeking this out.
Because then, you're flirting with it,
like demonic activity,
as something that could be fun.
It's the same reason
that we were too old for "Harry Potter".
But yeah, we were on the
fringes of that movement
that was like, "If we were younger,
our parents wouldn't have allowed us
to read 'Harry Potter'."
Because of the sorcery.
And I think, my view was always,
I think, that if Satan existed
and at the time, I, definitely,
believed that he did,
that he was super crafty and super smart.
So, it would be like-
Right.
What's more strategic?
And I would say, it's
more strategic for Satan
to have some sort of subtle
influence over this professor
that I'm going to this class
and he is causing me
to doubt my worldview,
he's causing me to doubt
the truth of Christianity,
the legitimacy of the
resurrection or whatever,
like, this religion professor
is saying these things
that are challenging my worldview.
That guy is under the influence of Satan.
And Satan is gonna be much more impactful
in the world at large if he's
working through academia.
And so, you end up developing this view
that the principalities and the powers
of Satan and his minions,
are not in the "Ouija" board
that you can get off of
the shelf in "Walmart",
they're in the classroom.
Yep.
They're in the places that we're debating
and defining culture.
Yeah, changing with the times.
Right.
And according to the old Rhett,
the way that I changed,
and this is very much the outspoken view
of many people who talk about me and you
and from the Christian world,
is that we fell to the vices of Satan
that we are, were and still
are under demonic influences
and that's what's
guiding us at this point.
Oh, wow!
Yeah!
Well, of course, what else-
That's the scariest story ever.
Well, what else could it be?
Just somebody, learning that
it's, probably, not true?
That doesn't make any sense.
It couldn't just be that.
There's, also, this,
like, "Okay, what of
your own sinful nature
and like, your selfish
in-most desires drive you?"
So, it's like-
Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
You become your own God, yeah.
Also, tended to own my faults as my own,
more than, I would say, I
gave into the temptation
of some external satanic force.
Like, yeah, we could
have done it all our own
without the influence of Satan.
It just depends on what
your take is, I guess.
Let's go back to ghost.
Hi, my name's Ellie
and I have a somewhat spooky story,
per your "Twitter" request.
My grandmother haunts my entire family,
it's just a fact.
It's not in any sort of scary way.
She has a very distinct perfume smell
and anytime, she wants to
make her presence known,
we all smell it.
It's come up when we're
all together for holidays,
or I don't know, when
something big happens.
It came up most recently for me,
'cause I got a tattoo in her husband,
my grandfather's handwriting.
But yeah, it's more of
a comforting haunting.
But nonetheless, a haunting.
I hope, y'all have a great day.
Bye.
Well, that ain't gonna
happen, now, after that story,
I'm not having a great
day with your grandma,
just spraying perfume.
Perfume gives me a headache.
This is, probably, the scariest
story, I've heard today.
But you don't know,
if ghost perfume, that has
the same, sort of, impact.
Grandma ghost perfume,
is going to, like, make my brain hurt.
I mean, Jenna,
I mean, I don't know, if you ever think
about the awkward conversation
we had about your perfume.
But I think about it often.
What do you remember
about that conversation?
We were on tour in Toronto.
Oh!
Okay.
It was a little overcast.
I remember, exactly.
We were walking back from,
like, a lunch, or a breakfast,
back to the hotel
before you had your
performances that night.
And yeah, we were
walking along and it was-
The three of us, maybe?
The three of us,
it was the three of us.
And you were like, something about,
I can't remember, exactly, how it started,
but you were just, basically, like,
"The perfume that you wear,
sometimes, it gives me a headache."
And I was like, "Okay."
It was "Acqua Di Gioia", or something,
I can never pronounce it.
How committed were you to this perfume?
Was this your scent?
I wasn't fully committed.
I mean, it was the only-
If you died-
Yeah.
And your family wanted
to know your presence-
It wasn't my signature scent.
Would this be the scent that
you sprayed in the room?
It wasn't your signature.
Yeah, I still have it,
but I don't wear it around you, anymore.
But I've worn other perfumes
and you haven't had
that same reaction, so.
Because if you know, that
I would tell you if I did.
Yes.
If it did bother you,
just go ahead and tell me.
But yeah, I did wear other perfume
and you haven't made a comment.
If our interactions are-
it goes both ways.
If they become defined by something
that like, really, gives you a headache-
Yeah.
Or a toothache, or any type of ache.
I would hope, that you would tell me,
like, that's the communication climate
that we have created by me,
just in the nicest way possible,
telling you, "Don't
wear perfume around me."
Full stop.
I think, that the level of-
I didn't know, you were wearing
other perfumes around me.
I feel, kind of, betrayed.
But you're pushing your-
you know what?
I thought I said, "No perfume."
But I'm just joking, now.
You said that one.
You said that specific one.
But that's not, really,
what I was thinking.
I was thinking-
He, only, accepts, like, lotions
from "Bath & Body Works"
that smell like strawberries.
Yeah, but you're right,
you haven't given me a headache
from the way that you've
smelled, since then.
Just a headache from
how I talk to you guys?
No.
But I think, that the level
of perfume that you wear
during your life,
'cause some people,
really, go real, real hard
with how much fragrance they put on.
And maybe, if you have a very high level
and there's a saturation in your skin,
that can pass to the afterlife.
And I believe, I met someone,
who, this would be the case with,
just this couple of days ago.
I was going down to the
bottom of my driveway,
which is a hill to bring
the trash cans back up
to the top of the driveway.
And there was a young couple
that was getting into a car,
coming out of someone's house
and they got no closer than
50 feet, outside, okay?
And it was not windy.
And I smelled this woman,
or I smelled this woman's perfume.
It was so intense.
And as I ascended my driveway,
I was setting the trash cans down
at the top of my driveway
and could still smell it.
Well, you gotta clear that nasal passages,
you gotta blow out hard.
Well, the only point I'm making,
is that, well, a, I just feel
like that's overdoing it.
It's overdoing it.
But b, when that woman becomes a ghost,
she'll be a smelly ghost,
like this grandma.
Do you think,
this grandma, it's just she smells strong.
You don't think, she's, like, spraying it
and trying to communicate?
Oh, you think it's ghost perfume
that she's, like, coming in and tch, tch!
Yeah, that's, kind of, how I was thinking.
Well, I think, it somehow got through,
it got through.
I mean, some form of you gets through,
some form of your physical form, right?
The little girl was a little girl,
the face didn't come,
the face was left behind.
Yeah.
She didn't get to bring her face.
Right.
Sometimes, things don't transfer.
But I think, that if you've
saturated your epidermis
with this smell,
I think, that the people-
It can cross over, so, to speak.
The people, who make a decision
about what's important to you,
they're, like, looking at
the list and they're like
"Smelling like this is
important to this lady.
Let it through."
I think, this is-
They let the perfume through.
This is a cool one, though, right?
Cause it's like-
Yeah.
It's a happy haunting,
like, "I'm still here,
I haven't completely left."
Yeah.
It doesn't sound like
a rewarding experience
for the grandma though, you know?
It's like-
Well, you don't know what
it's like on the other side.
Yeah, I, really, don't, Rhett.
You don't know what it's like to-
I really don't.
To attend "Thanksgiving" as a ghost.
I mean, it might be horrible.
It might be like,
"Man, I wish, I could
eat that Turkey leg."
But it might be like,
"I have no taste for Turkey any longer.
It's just wonderful to see
my former family gather."
All right.
If this is where you're going,
let's just go with one from
the not-as-creepy category,
'cause I would like to break it up.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
So, my name is Jordan
and I think, that you guys
might, really, like this one.
Because I know, that you
guys are fans of "The Office"
and mine, sort of, revolves around that.
Okay.
So, my spooky story,
is that when I was about 13 or so,
I went with my family to Scranton
and we stayed at the Scranton Radisson
and we just had a whole weekend
where we visited all locations
that they mentioned in "The Office".
Really cool weekend,
except, at the Scranton Radisson,
apparently, there is a history
there of it being haunted
and if you look up pictures,
it definitely looks, kind
of, like, it's haunted.
And so, I, then, got a
little scared once we staying
and I realized that this
place is, probably, haunted
and I looked it up and there were stories.
And anyways, long story short,
my mom is a medium and I asked her
and she said, yeah, no,
she, definitely, is
picking up on some things.
So, all night, I was terrified
and when I woke up, I was like,
"Okay, cool, we did it.
We got through the weekend
and there was no incidents."
And then, of course, right
as I'm about to leave,
I unplug my charger from the wall
and I swear to you,
my fingers were not
touching anything else.
It was not touching the wall,
nothing was sticking out.
When I unplugged it,
my finger got cut and
really bad and was bleeding
and it's, just, non-stop
blood the whole way back.
And I swear to you,
there's nothing around,
nothing poking out.
So, yeah, that was my story.
Thanks, guys.
Appreciate it.
So, a Radisson ghost.
We appreciate you.
Did the dude cut his finger?
His mom's a medium, though.
I don't know, what to make of this one.
It, almost, seemed as
creepy as the other one.
I'm about to say, it is-
I thought, it was in the
not-as-creepy category,
but like, until, like, the cut part,
like, it did, kind of,
fizzle out, you know?
But that's a good idea
for, like, a family trip.
If everybody watches "The Office".
I prefer watching "Survivor"
and then, going to Fiji.
But if you prefer watching "The Office"
and going at Scranton,
then, that can be your ball of chips.
You know, what I'm saying?
But they didn't film in Scranton.
I don't know.
Did they film exteriors in Scranton?
Is that what they did?
I hope, that they did.
They filmed in "LA",
they filmed most in "LA",
but I guess, they had exteriors there.
You having fun, you liking this?
Oh, I'm loving it.
Hi, you guys were looking
for spooky stories.
Yes.
Scariest thing that ever happened to me,
was I was babysitting,
I was looking after my
parents' house a few years back
and it was, kind of, getting
towards later in the evening
on one day while I was there
and I just was, kind of,
finishing up my errands
for the day.
So, I decided, I was
gonna take out the trash.
The garbage man would
come in the next morning.
So, felt like it was
the right thing to do.
So, I took the garbage out
and I remember very
specifically, on the way out,
looking at the digital clock
that's next to the computer
in the living room
as I was heading out
and it said, it was 6:07 PM.
And this was, kind of, in the summer,
so, it was light outside, still,
even though, I was in the evening.
So, took the garbage down
to the end of the driveway,
dropped it off, walked back to the house
and as an activity,
that should have taken no
more than a minute or two.
And then, all of a sudden,
when I closed the door,
it's like I blinked and
it was pitch-black outside
and I went and looked at the clock
and it said, it was 12:07 AM,
as in just after midnight.
I, like, toured around the
house, checked all the clocks,
all of them said the exact same thing.
And I, still, to this day,
have no idea what happened
during those six hours.
Ended up calling a friend of mine,
woke him up
and I went and slept at
his house for that night,
'cause I was just too freaked out.
So, yeah, that was my terrifying story.
What?
That's wild!
I mean-
This feels like-
Home alone, like, taking the trash,
like, nobody's at the house.
It's light and then, it's dark.
I don't know, if I would
call a friend after this.
I think, I would go to "WebMD".
I know, yeah.
You start to think, like,
"I had a time-lapse."
But she didn't,
it's not like, she like,
found herself crumpled up
on the floor,
like, coming to from
fainting or something.
It was-
Well, yeah, I know.
But I'd be freaked out, of course.
I would "Google" it from a friend's house
after I'd left the vicinity, yeah.
Yeah, I would think like,
"What happened to me,
like, happened to my brain?"
That's a scary on a medical level,
versus on a horror level,
kind of, a thing to me.
Because if you lost six hours-
But this the type of horror movie
that I would like to watch.
Yeah.
It's more psychological thriller.
Like, what happened to
you in those six hours?
Aliens, potentially.
Because that is a common thing
in stories of alien abduction,
is completely missed time.
I think, vampires can
also wipe your memory.
Yeah, they suck your
memory out with your blood.
I don't know, what it could be,
the strange perfume of a
grandmother, or a neighbor.
Well-
I don't know.
In "What We Do in the
Shadows", they can easily-
Yeah, that's what I was referring to.
That's where I learned all
my vampire knowledge from.
Yeah.
But, like, that's a good story.
I mean, it's one of those things
that, like, when it happens to you,
yeah, I mean, she's had no
other symptoms since then,
obviously.
It reminds me of the book,
"The Midnight Library".
If you've-
I have read it.
Yeah, where you can jump
into another version of yourself
to see if that's the
life you want to live.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, it's like a multiversal-
So, maybe, somebody assumed
her life for six hours.
A version of her assumed
And then, you, suddenly-
And then, decided they didn't want it.
Yeah.
So, she just concluded like,
"Oh, my life's not good
enough to be taken over
by another version of myself?"
Yeah.
Okay.
It's a fascinating-
It's a really good book, yeah.
Hmm.
It's an adult book, huh?
Is it a children's book?
Are you talking about
reading this recently or?
It's an adult book.
Yeah.
Okay.
But young adults could read it, easy.
Yeah, that's freaky.
What about this one?
Hey, Rhett and Link.
Okay, so, here is my disturbing
slash spooky experience.
So, some friends and I were
driving home from a concert
and we lived in Michigan
and we were driving home
from Chicago to Michigan.
And it was pretty late
and one of our friends was
asleep in the back seat
and then, the three other of us were awake
and well, obviously.
And so, we were just driving along
and we were all really tired.
And so, when we were driving,
I saw what looked to be
about a six-and-a-half to
seven-foot tall man slash dog,
walking alongside the highway.
And I thought, I was hallucinating it
and I said, "Oh my god!
And I'm hallucinating!"
And he goes, my friend
who was driving, goes,
"No, I saw that, too."
And our friend in the back seat,
the one who was awake, goes,
"I saw it, too!
It was a dogman!"
And we were all like, "Holy !"
Oh, can I swear on here?
Sorry.
And our friend who was sleeping woke up
and was like, "What did we see?"
And I was like, "You didn't see anything."
You were asleep.
But yeah,
we've all been really freaked
out about it, since then.
We've looked it up
and, apparently, there's something called
the dogman of Michigan.
It's like, I never knew about it before,
until we looked it up.
But it's a thing, people see him.
Kind of, crazy.
Hmm.
Well, when you experienced something-
Bye, guys.
Oh, she said, "Bye, guys."
That scared me.
Like, the fact that-
It's the dogman.
"Bye, guys."
Like I, literally, got-
I thought it was, "Hi, guys."
I, literally, got scared.
"Hi, guys, it's the dogman."
I thought, I was playing
another voicemail.
"I'm here in your computer."
I mean, when you get in this zone
of, like, being, like,
exposed to this type of stuff,
I'm going to go home tonight,
I'm gonna put the trash
cans back around in the dark
and I'm gonna do what I do
when I start thinking
about these type of things
and I'm gonna have to
run back in the house,
like, I'm on record,
saying, I've had to do it,
I'm gonna do it again after this.
You ever take a bat or anything out there?
I don't.
I don't have a bat.
You think, anyone allows me
to have weapons in my own house?
No, there's nothing that you,
like a fire poker,
I don't even have a fire poker,
like, I have one of those things
where you can make s'mores.
I have a bat under my bed.
I have a bat that is made
for, like, hitting intruders with.
That, it's made out of, like, a composite
and it's really heavy
and I think, it has a piece
of metal inside of it.
I think, the one I got, it's too big,
like, I feel like I-
You can't wield it.
It's a little too heavy,
but if I catch you with it,
it's over, man.
But it's, 'cause it's
not like a wooden bat,
'cause if you hit somebody
with a wooden bat, it'll break.
Can you throw it?
'Cause that needs-
You could.
It needs to have throwing
stars in the bottom of it.
But the thing about this is,
again, there's two other people in the car
and the first, she's
like, "I'm hallucinating."
I love this story, this is my favorite.
Then, they'll be like, everybody's like,
"No, I saw something, too.
I saw a dogman."
It's like, "I saw a dogman."
And then, it turns out,
so, there's corroboration
within the vehicle
of, "I didn't tell you it was a dogman.
I just said, I hallucinated.
You said, it was a dogman and I agree."
And then, you start looking it up
and there is a dogman of Michigan,
that they didn't know about beforehand?
Okay.
Like, this is really coming together.
I said, that we weren't gonna do this,
but I have to do it on this one.
Because for me, this is
the easiest one for me.
This one's not scary to me, because-
Oh, really?
Yeah, because there's somebody,
dressing up like a dogman in Michigan.
And I would do this and I may
do this in my older years,
assume a creepy identity
of some sort of creature
and be seen in a state.
You're large, dude.
You are freaking large.
Yeah.
Well, to think about it,
if you take, like, an average-sized dude,
six-feet tall
and he puts some sort of-
Head piece.
Head piece on that's a dog
and he puts on some,
like, tattered clothing
and he is like,
"Yeah, I walked down the
side of the street, here
and then, I have a little place
where I can go back into the
woods where people stop."
And it's fun.
There is a risk to that guy's-
Getting shot or something.
Yeah, for real.
I mean, I wouldn't do that.
That's really high risk in that way.
I think, it would be cool to do it.
It'd be cool to know that you did it.
Oh, to be friends with the dogman?
It'd be cool to be
friends with you, dogman.
So, that, like, I mean to do it
for, like, on and off for a month
and then, start to search online
to see when people start to talk about it.
That would be fun.
But what-
That's a long play.
But we gotta come up with my persona,
'cause it can't be dogman,
'cause that's taken.
I don't think, you should do this,
'cause I don't want you to get shot.
Because my other part of this,
is if you were there and it
happened the way it happened,
would you stop and turn around,
not knowing that it was a
dogman in Michigan, until later?
Hell, yeah.
I'd stop and turn around.
I don't know if you would.
I think, you would be too scared.
What?
I think, you'd be on the fence.
Now, if you were going there
to see the dogman in Michigan,
like, you were Ryan and Shane,
doing an episode of "Ghost Files",
of course, this is,
exactly, what you wanted.
You would turn around
and you'd be going on through
the woods, filming stuff
and yes, I would be there
for that.
I think, I'm gonna walk,
I'm gonna walk the "PCH".
But if you didn't know-
So, I'm right next to the beach.
I don't know, that you would stop, dude.
And I'm barnacle man and it's just a man,
it looks like a dead dude,
covered in barnacles.
Barney, the barnacle man.
I mean, I'm not gonna give you a name.
Barney-cle.
And I, kind of, like, scrape along
across the bridges and stuff.
Barnacle man of the "PCH".
I mean, if you got shot,
then, I don't think they would be-
You're less likely to
get shot in California
for being a barnacle man
than you are in Michigan.
Well, that's true.
You know, what I'm saying?
I'm, definitely, not
doing it in the South.
You'd be like, "Deer man, lasted a week."
This one is a California one
if you're talking about California.
Hey, Rhett and Link,
my name is Janelle.
I'm a long-time listener,
first-time caller.
Hey.
And I grew up in Camarillo, California,
you may have driven through
on your way to Santa
Barbara or like, Ventura.
Mm-hmm .
And we have "California
State Channel Islands",
located in Camarillo,
which used to be
"Camarillo State Hospital".
And it's pretty done-up these days,
it doesn't look quite as run-down.
But it's still pretty creepy.
And growing up, we used to go out there
around Halloween time
and try and scare ourselves.
And there's, like, an old dairy,
'cause the hospital was self-sufficient
and that part is still
super run-down and creepy.
There's a lot of urban
legends about the place.
And, yeah.
And I, actually, went to
college there as it was "CSUCI"
and that was really
creepy after late classes.
You'd, kind of, see stuff,
you're not supposed to see
and it's bars on the
windows and everything.
And fun fact,
my great-grandpa died there,
so, that makes it less scary for me,
'causes it's just old gramps, hanging out.
All right, see ya.
Is it on one of the islands?
Is that what she said?
No, it's on the mainland
and "Hotel California", this song,
is about this mental institution?
Huh.
I've heard so many things
about "Hotel California"
that it's like, there's, probably,
I think, there's five other theories.
But like, I don't know, if
this is like an "Eagles",
Brian, I'm asking you
if this is like a "Eagles",
have gone on record, saying that.
'Cause it's like, they don't know.
I've heard-
There's a place in Mexico.
Really?
I've heard this a lot, like, growing up,
I used to hear about this all the time,
like, everybody that would go
to "Cal State Channel Islands"
would always come back-
Said they went to "Hotel California"?
Yeah.
That's cool.
So, yeah, it's the narrative
that I grew up with.
Yeah, the mental institution,
which I don't know, if they
even call 'em that anymore,
is like, I mean, if I grew up there,
I could, definitely, see
that in, like, high school,
we would've done that,
gone out there and like,
egged each other on.
I'm really surprised that we didn't,
like, as much as you're
into this stuff, now,
you weren't quite, and you like
to scare all of our friends,
like, we were into camping in
the woods and stuff like that.
But we never got into this
spooky thing in the way
that like, nowadays, it's such a trend.
We didn't have the internet.
We didn't have the internet, you're right.
And we did, it's-
You had to know somebody, who knew it.
Urban legends-
If we were in high school, now-
Yeah.
We would have organized
these kinds of trips
and every state's got 'em,
but there are multiple, like,
legends in North Carolina
about lights and ghosts
and stuff, you know?
I know, we just, kind
of, missed all of that.
I feel sad for us,
but I'm, kind of, glad at the same time.
All right, let's, this
one looks interesting.
Hey, what's up, guys?
Calling for the spooky experience.
So, I was in fifth or sixth grade
and my dad took me to the
Amazon for a canoe trip
and we had been down
there for a couple days,
we're canoeing, we're feeling the vibe
and one day, we're canoeing,
it's the middle of the
day, bright, sunny day
and I'm canoeing along and
we passed this river bank
and what I see, really, freaked me out.
It was a clown.
And I know, clowns are
this, like, crazy thing, now
and people are scared of clowns.
But it just was a clown.
It wasn't doing anything spooky,
it was just standing there.
That's spooky.
I didn't know how to react.
So, I looked to my dad
and I'm about to tell him,
but I see his face
and his face ,
was, I've never seen my dad scared before
and that's all I can describe it as.
And I say to him, I'm
like, "What's wrong?"
And he goes, "Oh, I can't tell you."
And I go, "Tell me, please, just tell me."
And he looks at me and goes,
"I think, I saw a clown."
We never talk about it,
we never asked anyone about it,
we just kept going down the river.
And so, from that day on,
me and my dad have this strange
"Clown in the Amazon" story.
Then, that's it.
How're you doing?
That's enough.
Happy Halloween.
That is, I mean, that's freaky.
Again, you could make the
dogman in Michigan explanation,
here,
somebody in Amazon-
It would be helpful to know,
like, where on the Amazon they were?
Were they, like, in a dense area
where there was no towns, or whatever?
I mean, even though, clowns are creepy,
people still choose to be them.
Right.
There are people, who just like clowns
and I guess, clowns gotta
go to the river, sometimes.
And just stand.
Well, wouldn't you, though?
Again-
I feel like, his arms,
were like, totally, limping at his sides
and he was motionless-
Well, there was a clown, going around.
But then, his did turn,
it was like, that's the
only thing that moved,
was, like, his head turn.
Yeah, that would be great.
And then, his smile got bigger,
like, that's the only thing that moved.
There was a clown that was going around-
It's like his hands really heavy.
Somewhere in the United
States, pretty recent,
not recently, but in the last few years,
there was a repeated clown sighting,
maybe, in "LA", I don't know.
But this is, again-
No, it was, yeah, it was-
I think, about the
people, who are like me.
And again, I don't do this,
because I don't have enough free time
and I, really, don't
wanna put on the makeup
and the costume.
But I, totally, get the idea
of, "I'm just going to do this thing
that's gonna freak people
out and get people stories."
That's, exactly, what that was.
I think, it was multiple
people, dressing up like clowns
and just being places
and it, really, started
freaking out people
and, like, they started to,
it was like a, there was
a rash of clown sightings
and it started raising other questions
about, like, "Okay, what are they after?"
Yeah.
And it could be an innocent prank,
but it could, also, be something.
Yeah, that's why, you don't wanna dress up
like somebody, man.
I mean, I wonder, if any of
those clowns got attacked.
I don't think, anybody
would attack barnacle boy.
All right, fine.
Just leave me out of it.
Let's wrap it up with this one.
Hey, guys, Brad, here.
Long-time fan, I love what you guys do.
Thank you.
This is in response to
the spooky story tweet
that you guys put out there.
So, this one's a bit of a doozy.
I have sleep paralysis, occasionally
and a few years ago, I ,
but this time, it felt different.
I sunk through my bed, through the floor
and landed in my kitchen,
is what it felt like.
And I felt this tingling
sensation behind me.
And when I turned around,
there was a giant black mass
with a letter on the table behind it.
So, I approached the letter
and I opened it and it's empty.
There's nothing on it.
But like, Tom Riddle's
diary in "Harry Potter",
the letter is being written
real-time in front of me.
And for the sake of the story,
I'm gonna use the name Rebecca,
but the letter said, "Thank
you for taking care of Rebecca.
I really appreciate it.
All the people in Rebecca's
life, treat her very poorly,
but you're the only person
that, actually, takes care of her.
So, thank you.
Love, Rebecca's grandmother."
And then, in that moment, when I finished,
I got forwarded up
through the floor, again,
landed in my bed and shot
up and gasped for air,
it was just so crazy.
So, the next day I contacted Rebecca
and I said, "This might sound weird,
but I think, I was visited by
your grandmother in my sleep."
And Rebecca responds with,
"That's not weird at all.
My grandmother visits me
in my sleep all the time."
And then, I said, "She
left me a thank you letter,
what do you think, that
has to do with anything?"
And Rebecca said
that her grandmother
left letters for anybody
and it didn't matter if they
invited her over for dinner,
they would get a thank-you letter.
And when she sent me a
photo of an existing letter,
it was the same
handwriting as in my dream.
Ahh!
And I am not joking, it was insane.
But anyway,
I hope, that's a good one and
Happy Halloween, everybody.
Oh, god!
Oh, my God!
Hey, that was, Ryan said,
"Leave that one for last."
But it was a good one, again.
I think, that the moral, here,
is that ghosts can be good.
If they are grandmas.
Yeah, especially, grandma ghosts.
Man, that's crazy!
You've had sleep paralysis,
that's scary in and of itself, right?
But I've never seen,
lots of people see the black
figure, like the black mass.
Mm-hmm .
And like, there's a name for it,
like, the sleep paralysis
demon, or something like that.
I haven't had it in many years,
but I used to have it all the
time as a kid and a teenager
and then, into my twenties.
But it's, probably, happened once or twice
in the past 15 years.
But it's never been scary on,
like, a supernatural level,
or I've seen anything.
It's just makes me very
scared for my, like, safety,
like, I'm not gonna be stuck like this.
You're not thinking
straight in the moment,
'cause you're, like, half-awake.
But I've, definitely, never
been transported to a kitchen
and read somebody's grandma's note.
I wish, I had.
And to get a thank-you
letter from a ghost,
written in real-time.
That's pretty cool, man.
It's pretty cool.
Talk about feeling validated
for something you did.
Yeah.
That's better than a trophy,
or a medal, or like, a ribbon
that you wear around your neck,
ghost letters.
I mean, Christy's-
A whole series of books.
Christy's parents told her
that, like, "Don't do
anything, you shouldn't do
with your boyfriend,
because your dead grandma's watching,"
like, that's, literally,
what they told her and-
It worked.
Yeah, like, Christy said it worked
and it was like,
"This is kind of corroboration, you know?"
It's like, "What is
grandma seeing, you know?
With a letter she could write about me."
I'm just grateful that my
nanny didn't pass away,
until I was an adult.
I thought about this many
times as a teenager, just-
First of all, I'm grateful
that my nanny didn't pass away,
until when she did,
because I loved my nanny.
But I guess as, like, a correlation,
I would, also, not want
any nannies watching me
in the stuff that I-
Well, but this is the thing.
Grandmas know that people masturbate.
Grandmas know.
And so-
Well, I mean, I wasn't
just thinking about-
I thought about this
as a masturbating teen,
who had a dead grandmother
and I was like, "If my
ancestors, including my grandma,
granny was her name,
can see me doing this, it's just like,
well, she can also look away," you know?
'Cause she could choose
to see anyone masturbating
and everywhere she's gonna look,
she's gonna see somebody masturbating.
Yeah, but when all of your
ancestors are gathered around,
watching you masturbate,
if granny looks away,
she's gonna feel, like, the peer-pressure
of like, "Don't look away, granny!"
Again, going back to
the ghost-orientation,
I think, like, page two is like,
"Let's talk about masturbation.
You're gonna see a lot of it.
And you didn't see a whole
lot of it in your waking life,
but this is pretty much-"
This is gonna define your afterlife.
It's like,
"Look, you're gonna see
so much whacking-off
that you're gonna become
completely desensitized to it
and you're going to see your
grandkids whacking off, okay?
It's just part of the deal."
And then people, "Any questions?"
It's like, "Do I have to look?"
It's like, "You don't have to look,
but you might as well, start looking,
because everyone does it, guys."
I mean-
So, I thought about this as a kid
and I got over it very quickly.
It's a good idea for a show.
I mean, it's like, basically,
what you just pitched,
was like, the ghost version of
"What We Do in the Shadows",
like, the way, they approach
the world of vampires.
It's like, how does this,
practically, play out
from the ghost perspective, you know?
All right, let's make that TV show.
I'm sure, it's been done,
but, like, I would love
to see them do it and I-
Let's go around town
and pitch that TV show
and be told why no one
will let us make it.
Let's do that, that's fun.
No, we don't do that.
But I do think, the more I think about it,
I think, there was a
New Zealand-based show
that was a companion show to-
"What We Do in the Shadows".
That's more of, like, a paranormal-
I thought, they were
doing a werewolf spin-off.
I think, they're doing that, too.
So, anyway, I'm pretty sure,
it already already exists.
'Cause I've watched one episode.
It was just really hard to understand
and I didn't know, how to
turn subtitles on, yet.
Can't remember what it's called-
Bummer.
You got a rec for us?
Okay.
Yeah, I got a rec for us,
especially, if you wanna,
like, cleanse your brain
of, like, all this scary stuff,
so, that when you take out your trash,
you don't have to sprint back in,
like, there's a happy place
that I, now, find myself
going to a lot on "TikTok".
So, this is a "TikTok" recommendation.
Jewel, the artist known as Jewel,
the Canadian blonde woman,
who sang the songs in the nineties,
she loves "TikTok".
Okay.
And she's got a great sense of humor,
she tells some great stories,
she will go on hikes and she
will show you amazing vistas
and she has catchphrases.
I think, her main catchphrase
is something to the effect of,
"Would you get a load of the bull-
that I got going on today?"
Like, this is what she says.
And her teeth are perfectly imperfect,
like, she's decided that
that's not something,
she's ever gonna change about herself
and I love her for it,
like, I mean, she's a
beautiful person inside and out
and it's just like-
Tell us more.
She'll make you happy
and like, I would love to be her friend,
like, I'm not saying
I have a crush on her.
It sounds like you are, which is fine.
I think, I do have a crush on her,
but I, really, just want to be her friend,
like, I, really, want
to go on a hike with her
and sometimes, if she's on tour,
like, she doesn't seem
like she has any friends,
because you never see anybody
in her videos, except for her.
But she takes ice baths,
she tells stories of, like, growing up
in wherever the hell
she's, actually, from like-
Alaska, right?
I guess, yeah, it's Alaska.
Yeah, but I think, she was
talking about, like, her uncle,
who's, like, from Iceland.
She tells funny stories about
her relatives like that.
There it is, man.
Jewel.
Follow jewel on "TikTok".
You're welcome.
Thank you for all your
stories, your calling.
It's very fun, very fun.
I'm not gonna sleep well
tonight, thanks to you.
"#EarBiscuits", let us
know what you think.
"1-888-EARPOD1".
Okay, here's my spooky story.
I know, a lady and she
had a vacuum cleaner,
I was trying to borrow at "Shop-Vac"
and we were looking in
the shop in her shed
for the "Shop-Vac" and her
husband had recently died,
we could not find the hose for the vacuum.
And a voice, from nowhere,
whispered in my ear,
"Look inside."
And I said, "Hey, I
think, Jim is telling us
to look inside."
And sure enough, she
looked inside the vacuum
and there was the hose.
That's my story.
Hey, my name is Justin.
I was not a big believer
in the supernatural,
until one night, while I
was in bed with my ex-wife,
who, I, now, believe to be
personally, legitimately haunted.
I woke up to a scream from her
and I saw a guy like, half,
sort of, bent over our bed
and he was there and then,
he's gone, all of a sudden.
We compared notes later on
and we either had the
craziest shared dream,
or something was there with us.
And this is just one of,
like, a few instances
that led me to believing in
the things that I do now.
Thanks for listening.
We love you.
Hey, guys, this is Jamie.
I'm, actually, on a paranormal
team and I've had a couple,
but my favorite,
was I was sitting at a
local haunted attraction
when I heard a whisper that said,
"We're coming, Jamie,"
which is my name
and then, everything on my
rear-view mirror started to blow
as if the wind was blowing on it.
But there was no breeze,
there was no one around.
Then, we got home and the lights
turned on in our apartment,
so, we had to do a cleansing,
'cause it was pretty terrifying.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.